intense policing in central Paris helped
keep the city center quieter on Saturday
they're being called on social media for
protesters to gather here on the
chandelize
Nationwide 45 000 police officers had
been deployed
there were sporadic battles and tear gas
fired in Marseille flashpoints two in
Lyon but less intends than the previous
four nights of unrest says the interior
Minister the riots were sparked by the
shooting of 17 year old Niall M during a
police traffic stop in a suburb of Paris
on Tuesday
to my brother in the street because he
refused to stop we should be safe with
the police but we're scared of them that
is not normal
I said long simmering anger at racial
and economic equalities exploded
the police checked us at least four
times we are just here for justice we
are not here to break stuff
they mix everything up she's black and
therefore she must be like this he's
Arab so he is like this life is not like
that
the French Finance Minister said more
than 700 shops supermarkets and
restaurants have been looted or damaged
since Tuesday
when ale lived and died large crowds
turned out for his funeral on Saturday
with the many mourners who followed his
coffin continuing their calls for
justice
this latest unrest comes just as
Emmanuel macron was trying to reboot his
presidency following months of protests
over pension reforms now macron has been
forced to postpone a state visit to
Germany the police officer who shot Nile
has been charged with voluntary homicide
and remains in custody
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Paris